hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video selbst ich will gut drauf weil
hinter mir sonne blitzen tage hat sie
nur geregnet und heute scheint die sonne
und es ist schönes wetter und ich bin
ganz kurz vor den zwei millionen
abonnenten
aber wir kommen jetzt zum inhalt dieses
video ist nämlich eure videos widerrufen
hier konnte twitter wieder videos
einsenden wie das ok dann dann hat mich
das nächste video das man geschickt
wurde weil dieses hier
ich versuch das mal nach zu machen das
eigentlich klar von dem licht und der
farbe des videos werde dabei genau
hinter mir ist quasi dieses hält auch
ist wenn ich total erleuchtet aber das
ist irgendwie nur weil das von da alles
rein kommt von dem licht also ich hoffe
dass es gut aussieht wenn der nächsten
video einsendungen wurde mir wirklich
ein richtiger film zugesendet
und wenn man dieses intro gesehen hat
von wegen des perfekt directed by me
denkt wenn er von da kommt jetzt mit
übelster blockbuster oder so aber ich
zeige euch mal was da jetzt wirklich kam
als film
das war's muss ich da noch was zu sagen
was soll das was schickt mir für einen
scheiß 1 ohne spaß wo sind wir denn hier
gelandet auf dem kanal von luca ja okay
gut da da ist es natürlich standard
ich hätte echt voll krise wird euch halt
echt videos eingeblendet worden wo ein
windstoß einen klotz zum schmalz andere
youtuber bringen quality content und
machen alles mit up effekt und krasse
sachen und ich mache wo sind wir hier
nochmal auf dem kanal von luca da ist es
natürlich standard
da sage ich zu beginn noch so jung wie
geil die sonne ist da jetzt die sonne
weg die hat einfach keinen zweck das
nächste video beginnen wird
und da habe ich mir gedacht ja wo sind
die neuen israelis sind von annika suthe
sollte man wissen wenn man welche hat
ich dachte auf jeden fall da kommt jetzt
irgend so ein krasser shui expertin
macht er das so auf und zeigt sich auch
das sind meine neuen icx und diesen mega
cool stattdessen kommt der kanal von
luca ferra standard
ich hab angst vor dir oder schwarz
person content kann ich die sonne echt
verstehen dass die einfach abhaut wisst
ihr was ich habe laut dieser website
youtube
livescribe account gerade eine million
999 1894 896 895 abonnenten und diese
person die mir dieses video gerade von
der pizza eingesendet hat hat eine
schöne tolle komplette pizza gegessen
was hab ich grad gegessen eine schale
abgelaufenes müsli andere youtuber sind
nicht abgehoben aber ich glaube ich
bewege mich unter dem erdboden so weit
unten wie ich lebe ich esse abgelaufen
ist müßig betfair vielleicht danke sage
ich euch gerade was ich so zu essen habe
hier abgelaufene können und dann kommt
so ein hase und frisst einfach mich nie
gelandet auf dem kanal von luca ist der
standard luca ich würde dich halten geht
um eine wand findest gab seine waren
sofort machen du willst es finde ich es
schön aber deine kamera qualität zu der
kann ich sagen dass sie komplett
bescheuert ist bin ich schön dass ich an
einer wand hänge ich meine wenn ich
würde also da ist ein stein und da
großen schwerin und dann haben wir da da
hat auch einen stein das jetzt zu einem
video was derzeit so das komplette
internet bewegt wenn peer to peer oder
wie auch immer das heißt dieses video
wurde mir auch ein gesendet und ich weiß
nicht wie ich darauf reagieren soll ich
weiß nicht wie diese heiß zu stande kam
das kam irgendwie nach dieser apple
keynote der experten edwin vorgestellt
die sonne blendet mich der typ sagt heid
er hatten apple erhalten per abo band
unter donner und apple
das ist das video an
ich glaube nur was mit nachteilen apple
oder seid ihr ja er hat eine von apple
und mit einer puppe warum wird dieses
video so geheilt muss mal kurz die
dimensionen zu nennen das ist jetzt
nicht so dass das meeting ein paar
dollars hat eine million views hat
einfach 44 millionen views und jetzt mal
ein paar wochen paar tagen gemacht
vergleichswert ich mache monatlich 30
millionen views auf alle meine videos
zusammen und nicht mal meine monatlichen
sachen die chp kommen an seine hughes
nur bei den video run in den letzten es
ist unfassbar kraft wie das gerade durch
die decke geht ich kann nicht sagen
warum wir wurden zu gesetzen sondern
auch reagieren ich kann darauf nicht
reagiert hat schon vorher kannte aber
ich finde dass das ist also ich verstehe
es nicht
ist das der neue games teil das was ihr
vom video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn es uns
getan hat lasten like da und las auch
like da bin ich öfter wieder auf eure
videos reagiert sondern dass auch lang
da bin bei euch gerade die sonne scheint
und lasst auch online
wohnen findet ihr ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn er darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren der mega chillig
weil ich ja gerade android 2 millionen
bin und hier findet ihr das letzte video
eingeblendet wo ich auch auf videos von
euch reagiert hatten war auf jeden fall
auf der mega unterhaltsam und csu